okay so let's return you mentioned this
uh word superconductivity
so what does that have to do
with what we're talking about right okay
so in a semiconductor as i
tried to describe a second ago you can
sort of uh
in induce currents by applying voltages
and those have sort of typical
properties that you would expect from
some kind of a conductor those electrons
they don't just flow
perfectly without dissipation if an
electron collides with an imperfection
in the lattice or another electron it's
going to slow down it's going to lose
its momentum so you have to keep
applying that voltage in order to keep
the current flowing in a superconductor
something different happens if you get a
current to start flowing it will
continue to flow indefinitely there's
there's no dissipation so
that's crazy how does that happen well
it happens at low temperature and this
is crucial it has to it has to be a
a quite low temperature and
what what i'm talking about there i
for essentially all of our conversation
i'm going to be talking about
conventional superconductors
um sometimes called low tc
superconductors low critical temperature
superconductors
and so
those materials have to be
in at a temperature around say around 4
kelvin i mean their critical temperature
might be 10 kelvin something like that
but you want to operate them at around 4
kelvin 4 degrees above absolute zero and
what happens at
that temperature at very low
temperatures in certain materials is
that the the noise of
atoms moving around the lattice
vibrating electrons colliding with each
other that becomes sufficiently low that
the electrons can settle into this very
special state it's sometimes referred to
as a macroscopic quantum state because
if i had a piece of
superconducting material here let's say
niobium is a very typical
um
superconductor if i if i had a block of
niobium here and we cooled it below its
critical temperature
all of the electrons in that in that
superconducting state would be in one
coherent quantum state they would the
the wave function of that state
is described in terms of all of the
particles simultaneously but it extends
across macroscopic dimensions the size
of a whatever material the size of
whatever
block of that material i have sitting
here and the way that the way this
occurs is that
you know we let's try to be a little bit
light on the technical details but
essentially the electrons coordinate
with each other they they are able to
in this macroscopic quantum state
they're able to sort of
one can quickly take the place of the
other you can't tell electrons apart
they're what's known as identical
particles so if this electron
runs into a
defect that would otherwise cause it to
scatter
it can just sort of
almost miraculously avoid that defect
because it's not really in that location
it's part of a macroscopic quantum state
and the entire quantum state was not
scattered by that defect so you can get
a current that flows without dissipation
and that's called a supercurrent
that's
uh
sort of just very much scratching the
surface of of superconductivity there's
very deep and rich physics there which
is probably not
the main subject we need to go into
right now but it turns out that when you
have
this material you can you can do usual
things like make wires out of it so you
can get current to flow in in a straight
line on a chip but you can also make
other
devices that perform
different kinds of operations some of
them are kind of logic operations like
you like you'd get in a transistor the
most common or most um
i would say
diverse in its utility component is a
joseph's injunction it's not analogous
to a transistor in the sense that if you
apply a voltage here it changes how much
current flows from left to right but it
is analogous in sort of a sense of
it's the it's the go-to component that a
that a circuit engineer is going to use
to start to build up more complexity so
these are uh these junctions serve as
gates
they can they can serve as gates they
can so
i'm not sure how house
concerned to be with semantics but let
me just briefly say what a joseph's
injunction is and we can talk about
different ways that they can be used
basically if you have a superconducting
wire
and then a small
gap of
a different material that's not
superconducting an insulator or normal
metal and then another superconducting
wire on the other side that's a joseph's
injunction so it's sometimes referred to
as a superconducting weak link so you
have this
superconducting
state on one side and on the other side
and that the superconducting wave
function
actually tunnels across that gap and
when you when you create such a
physical entity it has very unusual
um current voltage
characteristics within in that gap
like like weird stuff through the entire
circuit so you can imagine suppose you
had a loop set up that had one of those
weak links in in the loop
current would flow in that loop
independent even if you hadn't applied a
voltage to it and that's called the
joseon effect so the fact that there's
this
phase difference in the quantum wave
function from one side of the tunneling
barrier to the other induces current to
flow so how does you change state right
exactly so how do you change state now
picture
if i have a
current bias coming down this line of my
circuit and there's a josephson junction
right in in the middle of it and now i
make another wire that goes around the
joseph's injunction so i have a loop
here a superconducting loop
i can add
current to that loop by exceeding the
critical current of that joseph's
injunction so
like any superconducting material
it can carry this supercurrent that i've
described this current that can
propagate without dissipation up to a
certain level and if you try and pass
more current than that through the
material it's going to become a
resistive material a normal normal
material so in the in the joseph's
injunction the same thing happens i can
bias it above its critical current and
then what it's going to do it's going to
add
a
quantized amount of current into that
loop and what i mean by quantized is
it's going to come in discrete packets
with a well-defined value of current so
in the
vernacular of of some people working in
this community
you would say
you pop a flux on into the loop so a
flux on you pop a flux on into the loop
yeah so effective skateboarder talk i
love it okay
sorry go ahead
a flexsign is one of these quantized
uh sort of uh
amounts of current that you can add to a
loop and this is a cartoon picture but i
think it's sufficient for our purpose so
which uh maybe it's useful to say
what is the speed at which these
discrete packets of current travel
because we'll be talking about light a
little bit it seems like the speed is
important the speed is important that's
an excellent question
sometimes i wonder where you
how you became so astute
but um so
this uh matrix four is coming out so
maybe that's related i'm not sure i'm
dressed for the job but i was trying to
get to become an extra matrix before it
didn't work out
anyway uh so what's the speed of these
packets you'll have to find another gig
i know i'm sorry um so the speed of the
pack is actually these flux ons these
these uh sort of pulses of of um
current that are generated by joseph's
injunctions they can actually propagate
very close to the speed of light uh
maybe something like a third of the
speed of light that's quite fast so
one of the reasons why joseph's
injunctions are appealing is because
their signals can propagate quite fast
and they can they can also switch very
fast what i mean by switch is perform
that operation that i described where
you add current to the loop
that can happen within um
a few tens of picoseconds so you can get
you can get devices that operate in the
hundreds of gigahertz range and by
comparison
most processors in our in our
conventional computers operate closer to
the the one gigahertz range maybe three
gigahertz seems to be kind of
where where those speeds have have
leveled out so the gamers listening to
this are getting really excited that
overclocked their system to like what is
it like four gigahertz or something 100
this sounds incredible uh can i just as
a tiny tangent is the
physics of this understood well how to
do this stably oh yes the physics is
understood well the physics of joseph's
injunctions is understood well the
technology's understood quite well too
the reasons why
it hasn't displaced silicon
microelectronics in conventional digital
computing
i think are more related to what i was
alluding to before about the the
myriad practical almost mundane aspects
of silicon that make it so useful
you can make a transistor ever smaller
and smaller
and it will still perform its digital
function quite well the same is not true
of a joseph's injunction you really they
don't they just it's not the same thing
that there's this feature that you can
keep making smaller and smaller and
it'll keep performing the same
operations this loop i described any
joseph's in circuit well i i want to be
careful i shouldn't say any joseph's in
circuit but many josephson circuits
the way they process information or the
way they perform whatever function it is
they're trying to do maybe it's sensing
a weak magnetic field
it depends on an interplay between the
junction and that loop and you can't
make that loop much smaller and it's not
for practical reasons that have to do
with lithography it's for fundamental
physical reasons about the way
the magnetic field interacts with that
superconducting material there's there
are physical limits that no matter how
good our technology got
those circuits would i think would never
be able to be scaled down to the the
densities that silicon microelectronics
can
i don't know if we mentioned is there
something interesting about the various
superconducting materials involved or is
it all there's a lot of stuff that's
interesting and it's not silicon
it's not silicon no so like it's some
materials that also required to be super
cold for calvin
yes so so let's dissect a couple of
those different things the super cold
part let me just
mention for your gamers out there that
are trying to clock it at four gigahertz
and would love to go to what kind of
cooling system can it be exactly 4
kelvin you need liquid helium and so
liquid helium is expensive it's
inconvenient you need a cryostat that
that sits there and
the energy consumption of that cryostat
is impracticable for it's not going in
your cell phone you're not so you can
picture holding your cell phone like
this and then something the size of you
know uh
a keg of beer or something on your back
to cool it like that makes no sense yeah
so if you if you're trying to make this
in consumer devices uh electronics that
are ubiquitous across society
superconductors are not in the race for
that for now but you're saying so we're
just to frame the conversation maybe the
thing we're focused on is computing
systems that serve as like as servers
like large yes large systems so so then
you can contrast what's going on in your
cell phone with what's going on at
one of the super computers um
colleague katie schuman invited us out
to oak ridge a few years ago so we got
to see titan and that was when they were
building summits so these are some high
performance super computers
uh out in tennessee and those are
filling entire rooms the size of
warehouses you know so once you're at
that level okay there you're already
putting a lot of power into cooling you
need cooling is part of your engineering
task that you have to deal with so there
it's not entirely obvious that cooling
to 4 kelvin
is out of the question it's it has not
happened yet and i can speak to why that
is in the digital domain if you're
interested
i think it's not going to happen i don't
think
i don't think superconductors are going
to replace semiconductors
for digital computation
um
there are a lot of reasons for that but
i think ultimately what it comes down to
is all things considered cooling
errors
scaling down to feature sizes all that
stuff semiconductors work better at the
system level is there some aspect of uh
just cur
curious about the historical momentum of
this is there some power to the momentum
of an industry that's mass manufacturing
using a certain material is this like a
titanic shifting like what's your sense
when a good idea comes along
how good does that idea need to be for
the titanic to start shifting
that's a that's an excellent question
that's an excellent way to to frame it
and you know
i don't know the answer to that but what
i think is okay so the the history of
the superconducting logic goes back to
the 70s ibm made a big push to do
superconducting digital computing in the
70s and they made some choices about
their
devices and their architectures and
things that
in hindsight were kind of doomed to fail
and i don't mean any disrespect for the
people that did it it was hard to see at
the time but then another generation of
superconducting logic was introduced
um i want to say the 90s
someone named likarev and seminov they
propose an entire family of circuits
based on joseph's injunctions that are
doing digital computing based on logic
gates and or
not these kinds of things
um
and they showed how it could go hundreds
of times faster than silicon
microelectronics and it was it's
extremely exciting i wasn't working in
the field at that time but later when i
went back and read the literature i was
just like wow this is this is so awesome
uh and so it you might think well
the reason why it didn't display silicon
is because silicon already had so much
momentum at that time
but that was the 90s silicon kept that
momentum because it had the simple way
to keep getting better you just make
features smaller and smaller so
you know it would have to be
i don't think it would have to be that
much better than silicon to displace it
but the problem is it's just not better
than silicon it might be better than
silicon in one metric speed of a
switching operation or power consumption
of a switching operation
but building a digital computer is a lot
more than just that elemental operation
it's
everything that goes into it including
the manufacturing including the
packaging including the
um
the you know various materials aspects
of things so
the reason why and even in even in some
of those early papers i can't remember
which one it was like said something
along the lines of
you can see how we could build an entire
family of digital electronic circuits
based on these components they could go
100 or more times faster than
semiconductor
logic gates
but i don't think that's the right way
to use superconducting electronic
circuits he didn't say what the right
way was but he basically said
digital logic trying to
steal the show from silicon is probably
not what these circuits are are most
suited to accomplish
you